[Music]
today we canceled darren rovell who is
i'm told by wikipedia a sports business
analyst who previously worked for espn
somehow this line of work has enabled
him to amass an enormous social media
following 2 million on twitter alone but
unfortunately for him
that enormous following only meant that
there was a very large audience
watching this week when he imploded like
a dying star creating a black hole of
cringe so potent and powerful that it
threatens to annihilate anything in its
orbit it all began when somebody on
twitter called uh called rovell racist
now not that it matters but from what i
can tell the initial charge of racism
came from some random account called bob
m
with literally one follower
so bob m with one follower argued that
rovell's stance against paying college
athletes is racist because he is quote
trying to cut off the only lifeline that
some of the poor underprivileged
minority college athletes are able to
get
now the issue of paying college athletes
is contentious there are reasonable
positions to be held on either side of
it
i happen to be in favor of it only
because otherwise the corrupt ncaa gets
to keep all the money profiting to the
tune of billions while pretending that
college athletics is amateur which is a
big joke
that's my opinion you might have a
different one
your opinion is wrong if it's different
but you know it's not racist
so ravel could have simply ignored bob m
with one follower but instead he felt
the need to defend himself sensing i
guess an opening to virtue signal rovell
responded quote
calling me a racist is cute
on this day especially i have one of the
largest martin luther king jr
collections in the world and some of my
closest friends are black
now you may be wondering what a martin
luther king jr collection is exactly
i mean he's an historical figure not a
pokemon
that's just one of the questions that
arises from this tweet though he
initially didn't seem eager to explain
it he deleted the tweet almost as
quickly as he posted it but it was too
late
the internet had gotten a hold of it and
it was on its way to going viral ravel
was mocked ruthlessly and deservedly and
he was also shocker of shockers
accused of being racist for denying that
he's racist
now you might think that that darren
would now crawl away into a cave
somewhere
hide there until all this blows over
protect whatever bit of his dignity
remains
but you'd be wrong
he was not done humiliating himself so
later that day
he called into some sort of miami
hurricanes fan broadcast
and tried to further defend himself
what you're about to hear is um
very real may sound like a comedy skit
or maybe a deleted scene from the office
but i assure you that this is real life
listen
to
the fan base so we everybody can get on
the same page
sure i have i have uh over
nine mlk signed items i am a humongous
fan of what he's done
uh and over the last seven years i've
collected
a lot of things uh it's not only mlk
it's a lot of black history i own a rosa
parks uh signed
naacp
card so it was pretty shocking today how
i was called racist um
when when i am a student and lover of
black history and it was it was i never
expected the reaction that i that i got
today
i'm so i'm sorry i'm sorry if people
think that a white man can't enjoy black
history all right i'm sorry i'm i'm
sorry i i i really am
i'm sorry if people think that a white
man uh can't uh
love martin luther king
but to me
that seems pretty counterintuitive
somehow amid all of that
perhaps the funniest part to me is when
he says of martin luther king i'm a
humongous fan of what he's done which is
the kind of thing you might say about a
tight end when he goes over a thousand
receiving yards on the season
and that was very funny though maybe not
as funny as bragging
that you have a rosa parks trading card
and i'm not impressed by that anyway
because i have the frederick douglass
rookie card and a signed limited edition
harriet tubman jersey
my anti-racist credentials are far more
impressive and worth more on amazon
incidentally
now as mentioned this self-defense
strategy by rovell not only led to
mockery laughter and derision all very
well warranted but also to further
charges of racism
deadspin ran an article with the
headline darren rovell is why white
america needs to leave mlk day alone
the article by karan phillips calls
ravel disgusting
a sadist and demented for what he just
heard there it was suggested that he
needs to quote take a crt class
which i'm sure he'll be more than
willing to do
um this is what he gets for showing off
his anti-racist resume
and and this is this is the lesson to
take away from this
what's wrong with what rovell said now
the popular view is that you shouldn't
try to prove you aren't racist by saying
you have black friends and that you
appreciate black history because
according to this view that only proves
all the more so that you're racist
but that's ridiculous of course i mean
in fact having black friends is
compelling evidence that you're not
racist against black people
admiring martin luther king jr is
another good piece of evidence it's
ridiculous to suggest that a man who
despises black people would nonetheless
surround himself with black people and
look up to black historical figures as
his personal heroes
so the problem with ravel's attempt to
prove he's not racist
isn't that he's incorrect
but that he's trying to prove he's not
racist
he is groveling before a mob of people
who will hate him regardless he's
presenting evidence in the court of
public opinion even though the verdict
has already been decided
darren rovell might be a cringy
self-important weirdo
but there's no reason to think he's
racist
unless you're the sort of person who
thinks everybody with his skin
pigmentation is racist
i mean think about that article
it it's it's not an attack just on
darren novell but he lumps in all white
people
white america
because we're all the same
in that case there's no evidence that
will ever convince you otherwise
and your opinion is irrelevant anyway
so why should anyone try to convince you
of anything who cares what you think
these days there are only two effective
and worthwhile responses to the racism
charge
one is to simply ignore it
and this is going to be the best course
of action 95 of the time
especially when the accusation is coming
from an anonymous account named bob with
one follower
the second option for the other five
percent
is to say to your accuser
i don't care that you think that
your opinion means nothing to me
your feelings are unimportant i have no
desire to be liked or respected by you
that's how completely irrelevant you are
to me
good day sir
now you can put that into your own words
but that's the message
under no circumstances should you ever
make any sincere attempt
to disprove the racism charge
the category of racism is so broad
and defined in such an arbitrary and ad
hoc way that it's it's unfalsifiable it
cannot be disproven
and at any rate the people who wield
this hammer are lazy manipulative
bullies
by trying to prove anything to them
you've lowered yourself not down to
their level but below it
you're now lying prostrate on the ground
kissing their feet and begging for mercy
which you will not receive it's pathetic
it's embarrassing
also kind of hilarious sometimes as
darren rovell demonstrates which is why
today he is finally canceled listen hit
that subscribe button right now do it
right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated